greetings from podcastville the joint is
brought to you by
lucy nicotine gum listen
i smoked a long time ago and it was a
nightmare to quit
but i was very smart because i used a
three or four prong approached
when you're craving a smoke you just
need a little something to satisfy the
habit
that's why i love lucy you take you step
outside you take a moment you pop this
a piece of gum in your mouth or a
lozenge and you're as good as new jack
a cigarette craving lasts like 90
seconds you got to look it up
it's a new year it's february what 15th
and you're still smoking going outside
in the freezing weather
you don't need to smoke anymore
especially with the guidelines
especially with what's going on
get lucy today so you're prepared when
you get the itch
today is monday today's when you quit
everything you start all over again it's
a second chance
to quit everything today's the day keep
it on you when you
you're craving it and subscribe so you
have it when you need it
lucy gum tastes [__] tremendous
the winter green the cinnamon the
pomegranate
it don't it don't even taste like
regular nicotine gum nicotine gum guys
that little wang to it
not lucy so if you don't like gum they
also got cherry ice flavored lozenge
that'll make your [__] wig spring my
favorite are definitely a pomegranate
and the cinnamon
give it a shot right now today go to
uncle joey
right now go to lucy.com lucy.com
that's what i want you to do go to lucy
dot co and use promo code joey
to get 20 off your products including
the gum
or the lozenges that's lucy dot co and
use promo code joey
at checkout also i got to give you this
disclaimer you know the warning
the product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical but go
to lucy.com
and be sure to use promo code joey and
quit smoking stop smoking
today it's a process it takes time a
couple months but you know what it's
gonna
what what's the result you end up in a
wheelchair face timing with your
relatives
forget it go to lucy.com
right now and try out their gum and
their license the joint is also brought
to you by
i love these guys surgery has been
easier because of c b
d lion people it's 20 21 and people are
still walking around going with dbd
what dvd well go to cbdline.com
and read the webpage they'll tell you
what types of cbd you got
cbd the cannabiloid cbd the cannabinoid
oil cbd
the cabinet null cbd the can
carry richard mean and cbda
which is a catabolic acid shown to help
you with depression this is that listen
how to start using cbd these are the
questions
you need to ask and not everybody's
going to tell you the truth
cbd lion go look at that second part of
the third party lab results
see for yourself don't even tell you how
cbd
works with your body maybe you're a
little heavy
maybe you know whatever go to cbd line
get the party started
and get 20 off when you put joey
or church in there i love cbd lion that
gummies
i mean tremendous the tincture works
right away
the vapor the kinesiology tape i put it
on
under the [__] ice you know this is
what i'm talking about
cbd lion is the way to go it starts
today
go to cbdline.com right now
and press in church or joey and get 20
delivered right to your crib i love you
guys let's get ready to start this
[Music]
is what's party
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 15th of february happy belated
valentine's day to all you lovers i hope
you got out and got your balls licked
and your dick sucked
hopefully you need some cbd line today
for your neck
you know you're eating that you got that
weird position in your neck
no light blue today today i decided to
go with my man felipe
and rodrigo the [__]
what's up full podcast just i love him
and i miss felipe and i uh figured i'd
put it on
i hope your weekend was great the
[__] dick went on
you know friday night uh my wife went
out i stayed at home with the baby and
watched the
whatever from sofa springs ooh
and then last night uh saturday night i
didn't do
well last night was valentine's day and
we just got some food from a restaurant
but we're only going to get reservations
and we just got it brought into the
house and uh we watched 60 minutes
nothing changes you know i'm a boring
[__] saturday night i was watching
[__]
the prelims and i was ready to watch the
[__] fight i wanted to bet one fight
on the card
okay i really like the deal that
draftkings gave
with the one punch i was definitely
gonna get it on that but i like the
bobby green fight but the bobby green
fighter got
cancelled i don't know if somebody got
covered something happened
and then i started watching the prelims
i watched the diego lima one and a buddy
of mine called from colorado in fact i'm
gonna put
he sent me a picture of my own phone
number and my own pager
from colorado i'm going to put like a
little vlog up on
patreon this week but the week was very
quiet my knees getting better
uh you know the pain is high but then i
want to give you
how can you have an opioid crisis when
you can't have none you can't get none
you know they give you nine pills for
eight days and tell you to take three
pills a day
the math don't [__] add up but
between the
leaves and the [__] cbd and the
and the [__] lotions i'm making it
through i think i got a couple more
weeks of physical therapy
uh i'm happy i did it it was a [__]
nightmare
but uh i'm happy i did it it's over with
them that's it and that's that
this week we're going to talk about
something that i've noticed that's been
going on
a lot lately and i have an explanation
for you for why it's going on
i feel bad for a lot of people who are
not used to this
world that people are going through this
but
you know the last six five
months every day i see something on
facebook
you know that's written uh facebook and
twitter
some derogatory comment either about me
or one of my friend comics or whatever
and
listen some people deserve what they're
getting you know even myself
you want to make a comment i'm fine with
it what do you want me to do you owe me
listen man unless you say it to my face
the comment they meant nothing
so that that's fine i don't i don't trip
on it or whatever you know
uh until i talked to lee and i talked
about it on the patreon
joey diaz project on the patreon that
you know lee was just getting so much
hate on his instagram but he turned off
his
comments you know he's just a sweet
[__] kid lisa yet
uh he's not cut out for this you know
let me tell you what what happens when
you get into comedy
you get the first four or five or six
years
you get so much rejection that either
you quit
or you get used to it and it just
doesn't bother you that's a lot of
people don't understand
that we get nothing but rejection
for five to six to seven to eight years
even now you get rejection it becomes
very easy but when a podcaster
goes into podcasting without having that
window of time those six years of people
telling you they hate you
they're only going to pay you 50 dollars
they told you they're going to pay you
100.
after you go through that you you could
learn to deal with other things
for a person like lee he could not
understand it and he would come to me
and i'd go leave
don't read those [__] things you know
you know for example
when i had lee with with me on the
podcast every week i had 10
people hit me up and say get rid of lee
and now that i don't have lee
i get 10 people with me up every week
and tell me to bring them back
so you know you you can't satisfy
everybody but right now we're living in
a world
of [__] hate we're living in a world
of hate
why are people hating so much you have
to ask yourself why
because they've lost their central
nervous
that their insides have been broken
the same way i believed in catholicism
and then god took my mother and i lost
faith in it is the same way people are
losing
faith in humanity that governments are
letting them down they're not sending
them money
they're not allowed to go to work
they're getting locked down
their children allowed to be not to be
go to school
people have been vanished you know
people are forced to do things they
didn't want to do
for some people i told you that this was
going to change a lot of people's minds
people going to really take a hard look
at themselves and see what the [__] my
next step is in life
but some people aren't doing that most
people are sitting there
in their house waiting for an
unemployment check
which my heart goes out to you you know
that
um their kids are on the computer they
gotta watch over their kids
the zoom breaks down or you know there's
a bunch of 18 year olds that this was
going to be that big year
they were going to go perform and go to
a major league college division one of
division two
and here we are with no sports and then
you got a bunch of 23 24 year olds that
were gonna be sent out into the world
you know in a proper [__] way and
they couldn't do it
because so every age group
whatever you know like cbs has 18 to 32
males and uh you know 34 to every group
is suffering right now and for some
people
some people are used to suffering if
when you read my book and you read my
childhood
there's a point you're going to close
the book and go i can't believe this
happened to this kid
and he kept [__] going that's why he
started becoming a burglar
and that's why because you only hurt
other people when you're hurt people are
hurt right now
they're hurt their boss is [__] on them
they got furloughed
you know for years your boss told you
you were the best employee in the world
now you [__] furloughed
i mean people have the right to be angry
right now
what people don't have the right to do
is to attack people okay let let's talk
what are we talking about here in my
world there's three situations right now
that have [__] bothered me in the
last two weeks four of them
number one i'm no andrew schultz for
years
sweetheart of a guy the guy's been going
after it for [__] years
with three hands you know there's just
some comics right now
tim dillon you know andrew schultz
i could name five or six of them hazel's
trail
that they don't give a [__] if it's a
pandemic they've strived even harder
they've strived harder than old timers
they've done better than me they've done
better than a lot of guys
am i jealous [__] no my dick gets hard
when i see people [__] still striving
[__] uh poor matt schultz was
supposed to shoot a special
and the pandemic [__] killed it did
that stop him no
he came out with a netflix show [__]
great show funny
all about andrew schultz boom all of a
sudden
some girl from eight years ago wrote all
these websites and wants to take him
down because he pissed on a shoe
or whatever the [__] is this right
even if it did happen what's it got to
do with it today you didn't raise your
hand
20 [__] years ago when it happened or
8 years ago i mean i don't know the
facts but the fact is that every time
somebody shines
somebody else comes in throws [__]
dirt on their [__] shine
i've never seen anything like this in my
life recently and we could go on and on
you've seen it
another gentleman ah look you've heard
me on podcast when i grew up in jersey
i wasn't a big bruce springsteen fan as
i got older
and as i got more mature as an adult i
listened to his music
and i enjoyed some of his music don't
believe the hype
i always liked born to run even when i
hated springsteen so don't believe me
don't believe him don't believe him
anyway but my point is that i've always
loved 10th avenue freeze out
it just wasn't my cup of tea i was into
maiden and sabbath and you know
[__] like zeppelin and all that stuff
but you know
i really hated what bruce stood for for
jersey in a way i liked
bon jovi that was just me i liked
sinatra that was just me
but at the end of the day he's a [__]
great talented [__] guy
he puts on a [__] great concert bruce
springsteen
and that's it so let's back this up
you're going to dui november 14th
nobody did you hear about the dui
november 15th did you hear about
december 15th
when did we hear about it the day after
his super bowl ad
think about that for five seconds you
guys are all
intelligent americans happiest i know
you have [__] like me
but the other half has a logic to your
mind think about it guy comes out with a
[__] [__] okay he's talking about
middle america and egypt who gives a
[__]
if you're still buying into that
political [__] you should be shot
and [__] hung
you should be shot and [__] we're
human beings
we're human beings i'm not on the right
i'm not on the left
my balls swing right down the [__]
middle i i don't i don't know what
i know what i like and i know what i
don't like i don't like
when you talk about politics my boner
goes away
that's what i don't like okay so you
know
whether you like it you don't like it
whatever i don't give a [__]
my point is he blows up a [__] great
commercial
and the next day a dui from november
14th
pops up hmm
that's [__] creepy don't you think
just like that a dui [__] pops up
didn't kill my buddy he didn't kill
nobody
he refused the breathalyzer which is not
bueno
you know there was a couple things he
did that were not bueno
does that mean i'm not a bruce
springsteen fan i mean he talked a lot
of [__] before the election that he was
gonna leave
maybe people are mad at him about that
listen we all have
uh we're all entitled to our opinions
i'm not talking about all that political
[__]
what i'm talking about are you seeing
this right now
are you seeing this another thing that
destroyed me last week was a girl
i never met her i think she's beautiful
she's still on tv
she worked on buffy the vampire slayer
what was buffy 22 years ago
20 years ago and this week she decides
to come out against josh walter now
from what i've heard about josh waldman
he's a piece of [__]
okay i'm not gonna lie to you i just
heard it you know you're a comic
you talk to different actors i'm no
disrespect josh walden
not that i want to be in one of your
movies but i'm not here to disrespect
nobody i'm just telling you what i heard
i heard that you're a [__] scumbag on
your sets and you're kind of weird
whatever
has nothing to do with me i've never
worked for you but
at the same time this is why i get mad i
don't know josh waldman i've never met
him
i've heard different things you know
when when i got to l.a buffy was a hot
show
and angel was odd show and you were
going for auditions for that i went in
for a fat ghoul one time for angel i
don't [__] know like a
fat zombo or something like that
i'm not here to piss nobody off but what
i'm saying is so 22 years later whatever
you decide this is the week for you to
say that this young man
didn't even sexually assault you nothing
like that he just abused you on the set
that when you were pregnant he called
you fat and then
he made you feel inferior well guess
what that's the job of every
seventy percent of directors i worked
with always started out trying to be
[__] johnny [__] mafia
until you pull them aside and go listen
how about i put that [__] lens in
your eyeballs and you'll [__] be
taping a movie from the left of your
life
from your eyeball you know you could say
it to them like that or you could pull
them aside and be a gentleman to them
and say i don't appreciate that
and then they usually don't use you
again
but who gives a [__] you spoke up for
yourself
so what you're going to do is speak up
for yourself now
22 years later that josh did whatever
the [__] he did
you know and then you got the man of
steel marilyn manson
am i a big fan of his no but i will no i
do like some of his music
i think i got one of his [__] albums
uh one of his uh
cds but i will tell you one thing
i heard that [__] i heard [__]
about in that way
[__] that i'm not gonna [__] repeat
and it wasn't all good
now if i told you
that my brother mikey if i heard all the
[__] i heard about
marilyn manson if i told you i heard
that about mikey but mikey and me were
cool
mike and me were cool mikey never tried
to you know
cattle pride me or put a [__] cue
ball up my ass
if mike gave me a cool 20-year cool
and
i've never seen this behavior in mike
i know he's out of his mind i know he
takes girls home i have a different
friend that's into all that [__]
they put balls in your mouth and [__]
whip you you know that's
that's not a one-night stand
that's a lifestyle for you people who
don't know it that's every day you're
gonna come home with a candle
they're gonna tie you up they're gonna
light it on fire go eat dinner with
their friends and come back and [__] you
when that when the [__] lent is when
the [__] the lent
the the candle wick is an inch from your
[__]
that's their world that's their world
that's what they do
trust me remember i told you a story
that uh i used to
tie up a girl and call her from a pay
phone what do you think i got the idea
from you think i invented that
my friend captain s m told me that
[__] idea
oh yeah he's got he's got no no duncan
no this is a
there's a kid a friend of mine from
boulder when i was in [__]
uh college that had thousands of stories
i guess his parents had hope had a
one of those type of shops like uh snm
shops and some [__] north dakota i
don't know
what do you put me on the spot for so he
would tell me about these stories
and i couldn't [__] beli there was
two times in my life i went off about
sex
95 when i started dating the stripper
and she was telling me the things that
she would do
threesomes and [__] pain guys paying
her rent and
you know she has to do his [__] once
a month i never heard of [__] like that
and the [__] other stuff from my
buddy who was totally crazy i never
heard
the [__] like that either you know
smacking feet and [__] just
it's just a crazy [__] world i would
see his girlfriend from time to time
black eyes are cast you know you need
this
why yeah i seen him one time with a
guest like he literally
i don't i don't know and i don't ask but
it's a [__] lifestyle so
now this girl wants to turn around and
say marilyn manson so what happened
this [__] agent dumped him the
[__] record label dumped him
he just recently married you know
whatever maybe he was turning his life
around
i don't [__] know but this type of
[__] has to just stop
you are ruining [__] lives you are
ruining
[__] careers you know last week i
don't know what happened again
i don't i don't know history remember i
was telling you guys i was trying to get
a history [__] course
so i could learn about history that i
have between the reefer
the drugs the fear the [__] my mind
i've forgotten all about history i don't
know nothing
i never met her i've never said two
words to her
i think she's pretty and i got i think
she's got the cutest little toes i've
ever seen in my life
if i was still on the market i would
suck a toes and bite on that little one
and that's gina carano she's got those
fat little italian toes
cutest [__] feet you ever seen in
your life i would bite one of those
like one of those spanish chicharrones
you ever see those spanish [__]
that's what her toes look like anyway i
got nothing against gina carano
she said something about jews getting
chased down the street
i don't [__] know they pulled the uta
fire
her agent's fire to the movie fire but i
see people coming to her defense
i see a lot more people coming to her
defense because
this has to stop this has to stop
this this anger that we have every time
somebody excels and we get mad at them
we're not all perfect
when you see johnny depp up in the
stairs on the theater wall
as much as i like johnny depp he's not
[__] perfect
you know i watched a movie uh saturday
night
i was trying i was starting to tell you
guys that i watched the movie saturday
night
[__] if you get a chance watch it
i was gonna go to sleep and when i saw
this movie was coming on i stayed on a
movie called midnight express
but a guy that goes to turkey and tries
to smuggle hash into the united states
and gets caught in turkey
i call lee immediately and i go lee i
don't mean to bother you it must have
been about midnight ago
i am watching my biggest [__] horror
show right now
if i tell you how scared i am of this
you would laugh he goes
what are you watching like i'm watching
midnight express
about a white dude that has to do time
in a turkish prison
can you imagine the first time my
breakfast gets served
and i got to see that hummus with those
[__] cannoli pads and whatever else
they eat over there i would [__] be
skinny i'd be down to
i looked like a [__] skeleton i
wouldn't eat that [__]
just to stink in that turkish jail
between no deodorant
and the old hummus it would kill me i
would just hang myself in a cell i
wouldn't [__]
i'd be like ronnie jeff treane whatever
his name is
jeffrey epstein i'm [__]
i wouldn't tolerate that [__] i don't
even know i got on that but anyway
what i'm trying to say is that you know
even with the andrew schultz thing i've
known andrew for a long time
i don't believe it and from what i'm
seeing the reaction is
a lot of people ain't buying it and i'm
telling you why
because this accusation thing now is
starting
to get old it's really starting to get
old
people are double taking you and going
what are you talking about
so 22 years ago you were on a set with
josh welton jumping up and down
buffy's the number one show on the wb
we're going to parties every night and
you were cashing a big
check and all of a sudden the show ends
you move on with your career
and now 22 years later you want to raise
your hand and say that you worked in a
toxic environment
let me talk to you people about
something
go to my mdb right now joey diaz imdb
i worked i'm not done i'm not somebody
who's telling this not a place
i'm not that guy that holds on to one
movie you know
i worked i worked and i was on a lot of
sets
and i got gotta tell you something 60 of
them
were [__] sets [__] sets
and you know what make some shitty sets
ego
that starts from the top from the
producers and the directors
to actors
you have too many clashes on a set
you have too many chiefs but not enough
[__] indians
so it makes every set toxic i'm going to
tell you a set i worked at
that had zero toxicity in it the many
saints in newark do you know why
come here i'll tell you a secret they
shot it in new york
nobody gives a [__] they shot it in new
york
and david chase made it a cold a closed
set which means you know a little [__]
agent with the white shoes that shows up
to all your events and hi
oh my god this is great now we can
mingle with other [__] that
don't know nothing about nothing
they wasn't allowed i mean my first two
days on the many saints in newark i'm
like this is great
and i asked somebody from l.a why is
shooting in [__]
l.a different from shooting in new york
and they said
ah no industry
and i looked around i was like oh my god
what a [__] difference
i remember shooting an episode of marin
with sally strothers
i loved john i loved mark i loved mark
for giving me the second episode
mark was great if you guys have seen and
in my episodes of marc
maron that [__] put a
firecracker under my ass
and let me do whatever i do that's why
no matter whatever happens in this
lifestyle
in this life i'll have mark maron down i
got his back
because when it came time down to acting
he didn't pull rank on me
he let joey diaz be [__] joey diaz
and when you watch that [__] episode
i went off those are the first two tv
episodes
i've ever gone [__] off on i forgot
where i was going to go with this
tangent but
[Laughter]
you see what happens when you smoke dope
early in the morning
but uh what was i talking about nothing
there was no
there was no onset you know when i got
to marin
all those [__] baron was great his
set was great the people
it was open set you know the the
executive producers were great the
[__] writers were great the writers
were superb
the problem with that set was there was
you know the episode i did
the one the first episode i did was me
burr
and uh maron and you got 30 agents there
at night and these are the same people
that wouldn't talk to me 10 years ago
and here i
am slinging dick in front of them
like you didn't like me before now
they're smiling at me like hi that was
great go [__]
tell your 20 years ago you told me i had
nothing to say on stage
now you're telling me i'm killing it on
here get the [__] out of here you know
most comics will take those compliments
and take them to the end of the [__]
you're not going to believe what he said
to me that guy says that to everybody
who gives a frenchman's [__]
who cares what he had to say to you that
shirt that set was not toxic
and if it was if you watch my
performance i made it very untoxic
because i said some wild [__] [__] in
there
so this is what i'm saying to you but
there were sets
that were oh and
guess what i would crack them every
[__] time
i would crack them every [__] time
there was a set i worked on one night
i sold i told this story on the church
but i'm willing to tell you again
that is one of the highlights of my life
when i have to write down the things i'm
most proud of
it was this because there's a video
online right now
me when i was still doing coke i'm
smoking a cigarette did you see it
it's [__] hard about something yeah
it's like
yeah my roommate the girl that uh
was a sloppy [__] drunk
and uh if you look at that person
that's not who i am anymore that's how
you know you changed me i've changed
eight times
since that [__] video you know the
longest yard
between you and i had a little toxicity
on it
not sexual i mean you think about it you
got wrestlers you got pro football
players
you got rappers you got a lot of
testosterone on the set
that one was toxic but not in the way
that
you think it was toxic it was toxic in
the way as
there were too many guys and there was a
couple confrontations a couple days
thank god no punches were thrown
that was a form of a different form of
toxicity
the toxic that i didn't like was when i
got on a set
and a director or a producer
spoke down to you
and it was really [__] crazy that i
tolerated it unknowingly
until i did cocaine
once i stopped doing cocaine and that
fog was released from my eyeballs
it became a different story for me
example there was two [__] examples
that happened with me
the first one was
a film that was
so [__] bad it was so [__] bad
i did it because there was three
examples to be honest with you
when i stopped doing blow and i [__]
just
couldn't take the [__] no more i
didn't like it i didn't like it i
i when i was green and i was
learning how to act and the addiction
the addiction
made me take it like
a cochor you know i was a
let's be honest i was acting like a
cocoa
i would let a producer say whatever the
[__] he wanted to me
because i needed that 600 paycheck to
continue my addiction
but after the addiction was gone and
that
lens that coke film went away from my
eyes
it really bothered me when i would go on
a set
and the first set was the set i told you
that the movie that made me quit cocaine
was a movie called boilermaker
they told me when i went to the
interview that they knew i had a coke
problem
and how was it going to affect the movie
and they said not to give them an answer
until tomorrow
because they want me to think about the
answer and i went home
i did what i always did i cried like a
[__] that i am
and i said i'm not going to
be able to know this i'm not going to be
able to do this movie
because these people know my secrets but
you know what at the end
i said let me go in there like a man and
between us
i stayed sober for the first 21 [__]
days of my
sobriety on that set because of that
movie
because of what that man said to me but
when you first become
sober you're not too [__] happy
you're not too [__] happy i'm a man
and there's different types of movies
that you guys don't understand
i want you to understand this so you
don't
think that joe is being greedy there is
your typical film where you get
scale which is i think 685. don't quote
me 6.95
if anybody knows tweet it to me 645
plus 10 that goes to your agent
they'll pay for your agent's fee but
after you get taxed and [__]
you don't see that so don't worry about
it
then you have you have your regular
scale and then you have
a modified scale which is probably 456 a
day
and then you have another scale that's
250 a day
you have another movie that's a hundred
a day low budget there's a hundred a day
no wardrobe you gotta bring your own
wardrobe and then there's ultra low
budget
which is fifty dollars a day for you
people who are thinking into going into
acting
know that when you start now for sure
especially with covid
you will be doing movies for 50 days
[__] you joey you don't know what you're
talking about you're a loser okay
don't listen to me they just tacked on
550 000
budget to every [__] covert
production either you do it
or you don't they're going to tell you
that they're doing it and they're going
to pocket the 550 000 and take the money
from you
and the producers are going to keep the
money that's exactly what they're going
to do
there's productions that are going to do
the covet thing
and they have to pay you less but i want
them to take less also we all lose out
on this
but trust me i know hollywood 90 of
hollywood
is gonna tell you they're doing covet
testing
that they're gonna do have all the
proper whatever the [__] you call it
procedures
but they're not gonna have it they're
gonna pay you less money they're going
to pocket that 550 000
i know that already going in because i
know how that [__] system works
but that's got nothing to do with me you
either accept the work
or you don't you call me for a movie now
i'll read the sides i'll put them on
tape
and before they say they want to offer
it to you we're going to do a conference
call with everybody
and i'm going to tell you what you're
going to expect because the first time i
don't see this
on your set bye-bye this is why i don't
go on the road right now
because the first time i see a little
co-video slip
on a comedy club bye bye
there's no there's no waiting around
there's no correction there's no nothing
you're talking about people's lives here
so for me
bye bye bye bye 550
000 and it adds a move it adds a million
dollars i think
every four weeks to a movie so if you're
gonna shoot an eight-week movie
you're gonna pay 2.5 million dollars in
covert costs
because the teamsters stuff like that
joey why are you telling us this we
don't give a [__] because
i'm letting you in to see the other side
of the [__] thing that nobody else
tells you
so the first [__] movie i went off on
when i started i always behaved myself
on movies yeah
i took the roller skates from basketball
and [__] like that
but i was always very respectful
i was always very respectful if you
disrespected me
i tried to one of the first farts on the
joint i'm back on the garlic pills we're
back [__] you know what i'm saying
i'm back like steve ooh that's [__]
garlic at its best you understand me
if you if you smelt that [__] thing
from your [__] face mass you die
i'd love to have like a tube that goes
into people's face masks like a hookah
like i'd be like a living hook and i
just fart and the [__] string goes
right into your face mask
and who could survive i
[__] love it but i went to the set
and i'm having a great time now
when you're doing a movie when you're
when you're a writer of a movie
a producer of a movie you're selling me
your dream
joey this has always been my dream mike
wants to write a script about his band
in in [__] camden in the good old
days
you know what i'm saying okay you want
to write this [__] movie let's write
this movie you're the
you're the whatever so now he comes to
me one day he hires what's called the
line producer
and a line producer comes in and looks
at the things in the script that can't
be done and could be done
that explosive right there that's gonna
cost you 18 million
all right get rid of that i thought it
would be great yeah it would be
but that's 18 million dollars less that
car chase is gonna cost you this
that [__] chick can come on the face
that's gonna cost you this
so you're gonna re do rewrites on the
script
you're gonna be able to be told what
your budget is
they're gonna tell you the hotels the
transportation
the food the labor cost they're gonna
allow up a percentage
for whatever you call that it might go
either way
and there you have your budget for a
film okay
now you go and search you go in search
of that budget
how you doing mr mrs uh
bob lalingus my name is joey diaz i do
films
i'm looking for investors uh it pays you
back
20 points after we get the copyright
licensing and blah blah blah
you were originally looking to get 8
million
but guess what you got 8 million but
then the pandemic hit
and 6.3
pulled up because there's no money now
they don't know how they're gonna get it
back
so now you're stuck with the same movie
but you have to shoot it for one point
whatever the difference is seven million
dollars
right if you have eight million dollar
more so now you gotta shoot it for 1.7
million dollars
now that means the actors rates go down
and for you to get a big name you're
gonna have to get a a
big name and give them a producer credit
so he makes
extra money in the back end if something
does happen
with those monies on the producer and so
i take this hundred dollar a day film i
get there the father from the fighter is
on there a couple great guys
are in this movie it's called
boilermaker
i get there the first [__] day you
know again
i'm quitting cocaine it's my third or
fourth day
i walk on the set i go over to craft
service craft service
is where they have apples cheese
crackers
peanut butter and jelly some coke cuts
maybe a couple pieces of cheese
maybe some greek yogurt coffee
teas sodas waters
it's a 100 a day movie i'm
i'm not looking for much right i'm not
i'm not expecting a [__] guy
with a prime rib with a [__] chef's
hat on you know
but i get to the table and there ain't
nothing on thursday
there's apples and some waters
okay i get that friday
nothing and they sent you out for lunch
which i had worked on 20 movies by then
nobody wants to send y'all to lunch what
happens if you're in your car you're
into an accident
what happens if you're in your car and
you're driving and you're [__] you
know
there's so many things that could happen
that when you're shooting a movie
people want you to stay there for lunch
they're gonna bring you everything they
can to keep you comfortable
or they're gonna try and and and that's
it they're gonna bring you
food for lunch i knew something was off
when they were like see you in an hour
go get your own lunch and i'm like what
the [__] is this
we're paying for our own [__] lunch
[__] you
saturday i go in there now this is a
movie that had to be shot 21 days in a
row there was no days off
saturday i go in there same situation
all right
now guess what sunday i go in there i'm
gonna tell you something
i don't mind working monday through
saturday for you
i love it you gave me the opportunity
i'm gonna go in there and
do the best job i can but sunday i want
you to know there's two things about
working on sundays with me
a we're not gonna do no 20 takes per
shot
it's three takes and let's go and b
we're gonna have a nice [__] lunch
we're a [__] team we're a movie we're
a family
you're gonna get some [__] food in
here caden and we're gonna sit together
for a half hour 45 minutes
just like we would do with our families
since we're missing our meals with our
family
that's the least you can do ooh i get
that [__] sunday
and i go to the table
dick guess what guys now i got
joey diaz has to be joey diaz not the
joey dears that
i love but the joey diaz that i [__]
hate
i got to go up to the dude and go dog
what's going on with the food here well
we're going to make a laundry list to
figure out i go since [__] thursday
since thursday you've been going to
figure out this this is four days this
is unacceptable
this is unfucking acceptable and i had
gotten a card from aftra like two years
earlier
i did this really bad pilot called
rafaellos
it's online there's a big story to that
too we don't have the time today
and they did the same thing the first
night you thought you were at a unicef
convention you know what i'm saying
black kids with flies on them there was
nothing to eat
and then the [__] next night i get
there and it's the taj mahal
they got shakes they got coffee machines
they got espresso you know why because
the [__] after guy was there that's
why
and i go what the [__] is this and he
goes yeah it's a good setup i go this
wasn't the way it was last night
he goes what are you talking about i go
last night
it was like skeleton night here last
night this was like [__] hiv night
that [__] gay bar everybody was
skinny
and they were giving out cherries that's
it there wasn't no food there wasn't
dick what the [__] is going on
he goes you ever go on a set again
and there's nothing to eat you take this
[__] card
so guys you know me dog i ain't no
[__] crime stopper and i don't want
to crime stop on nobody
but i went to them decently i didn't go
up to them like an animal
to my mother's [__] grave to mercy i
went up to the
executive producer like a man ago can i
talk to you for five minutes
i swear to god guys i pulled them aside
i go listen
that crap service table that thing got
hiv
that table's light and he's like well
we're trying to make a list together
since [__] thursday brother
and he goes well what do you want from
me like you get like
they give you [__] attitude that's
what burns me up the most when they give
you attitude like well if you don't
[__] like it i go
no i really don't like it i took the
card
and i go i'm gonna go to my car and call
this guy
and i'm not coming back till you have
that [__] food table ready
and i turned around and he's chasing me
joey this doesn't have to be ready
we could just give you 50 to go eat
lunch that's not the point
that's not the point guys the point is
that table
better be [__] filled up with food by
the time i get back i'm going home
i'm going home this shot like 20 minutes
from my house
i'm going home if you want to replace me
replace me for the hundred dollars a day
i'm not gonna lose nothing you know what
am i losing 100
a day after taxes and a ten dollar
commission what am i taking home anyway
you still gotta give a commission on
four hundred dollars a day and those
agents will take that ten dollar [__]
bill
even if you do three days on that movie
so i told them i'll call you call me
when you have the food back
when i got back up there it looked like
the taj mahal and they pulled me aside
and there were like four people that
didn't like me throughout the rest of
the [__] movie
i didn't give a frenchman's [__] they
didn't talk to me throughout the movie
but here's the best
of it one of the executive producers was
like a real
dick he was an older guy
and he came up to me he's like i didn't
appreciate what you told the other guy
you know what man
this is when i wasn't doing coke no more
i really don't give a [__]
what you don't appreciate i'm just
stating the obvious i'm just stating the
fact
are you an actor he goes i do it part
time i go then what the [__] are we
talking about here
i got to tell you to have the [__]
tables filled i got gotta tell you
so that wasn't the movie wraps i swear
to god the movie wraps like on a [__]
tuesday
and that friday i have an audition for
the dark knight
for batman they're gonna do a six-week
series
on one of these channels to go right
into
batman dark knight so when i get there
who do you think is there
[Laughter]
the [__] producer from [__]
boilermaker the old guy the one that
came up to me and said i didn't do the
right thing
by calling the sad guy [__] you
and when i got there when i
signed my name he actually made a remark
he made a remark to the casting director
that you might not want to get him
because he might complain about the
aftertable
i even gave that laugh too like
like see who's booking this [__] job
[__]
i heard him walk in i heard him do his
lame ass read
i went in there and just blew up the
[__] room like you [__] know
uncle joey could
there's certain times i could go in a
room and it's going to be lights out and
on that
particular [__] day it was lights out
and i walked out of there and i remember
seeing him packing this bag and i walked
up to him and i go
you ain't getting this one
even if i didn't get it i knew he wasn't
gonna get it he was too much of a
[__] stiff
that's why he produced movies so he
could put himself in his own movies
ah guess who got the batman roll
pop butt you could probably find that
he's the best
since i was a fat [__] remember after
the [__] this is 2007
i still had to be i was about probably
about 380 at the time they had to take
me to
rochester big and fat the fat man store
and they had to buy me my own little
[__] calvin klein suit like a 15
hundred dollar suit like a 300 shirt the
whole [__] thing
and we shot whatever we had a shot it
was like a two-hour shot it was like
stealing
and as i'm walking out the lady goes hey
do you want to buy this suit from us
we'll sell it to you for 1200 bucks
we could take it right out of your check
if you'd like
i looked at the suit and the shoes and
the thing and i gotta really use them
i go nah i i don't want them i can't
afford at night
as i came into the car the casting
director came out with a bag with the
suit the shoes the shirt
the cufflink and she goes hey you did a
great job merry christmas
and she gave me the [__] clothing i
think i still got the suit upstairs i
wear at the funerals and [__]
it's a black [__] suit
so do you understand me you have to if
you ever
go in any [__] position i don't care
if you're a [__] plumber
a doctor a lawyer you got to speak up
the conditions ain't right
my favorite [__] story about
directing is the one i went on
when i got the mafia commercial look up
hardee's
what's hardy is his other company it's
hardy
junior no it calls junior so carl's
julian hardy's in the same company so
when you do a commercial parties
they pay you for two payments hearties
and and i had to do a [__] commercial
for [__] this guy this director that
had like a [__] pigeon on his arm
like a
like a thing did i just talk about this
couple weeks ago yeah
he had like a tattoo and he rolled up
his sleeve and he wore like a
uh like a hat and he had a chinese
assistant which is the most racist thing
i ever saw in my life
and he would say little racist things to
her like
from the time i got there he was being a
dick and i could tell that like the
people that were working for him
were kind of weird and it was me and
this guy named
mossy we were the [__] actors he was
an italian guy and i'll never forget
that [__]
the car wouldn't stop for some reason it
was an escalade and it wouldn't stop
and he had been ragging people all
[__] night he had been ragging people
and finally he kept calling
me stupid how can you be so [__]
stupid
you [__] you know the brakes and i
[__]
i wasn't on coke and [__] it was like 3
30 in the morning we were at the long
beach dock
and i called the timeout and i walked up
to him and i go
i day to [__] call me stupid one more
time what the [__] does the matter with
you
and he's like you are [__] stupid you
cannot stop the [__] car
sorry about this i gotta check something
out here
so you can't [__] uh stop the car
whatever the [__] it was
you're a [__] dumb [__] he just kept
saying it over to everybody
and i just called the timeout and i went
up to him and i go you know what
[__] you man you can't talk to us like
this and he goes you're [__] fired
and he ran into his little [__] [__]
trailer
the little chinese guy ran behind them
it was hilarious only in
l.a could you see this type of [__] only
in l.a
and [__] i had a people were like
you're fired i'm like what you gonna do
at four in the morning
what are you gonna call the second
choice could you imagine being the
second choice for a commercial i'm
calling you at four in the morning hi
how are you our first choice quit do you
still want the job go [__] yourself
so i [__] knocked on this trailer
what a man does
and i go maybe i said some things i
shouldn't have said but you said a ton
of things that
you shouldn't have [__] said listen
we could [__] you could fire me and
you could go to
call of duty tomorrow and complain
what's that gonna get us
we're all here the commercial is almost
done
let's shoot the [__] commercial and
sure enough he [__]
came out i don't want to talk to you you
sure you don't because you got
embarrassed because
i told you the truth how to act like a
[__] man sure you don't want to
[__] come out here
so he [__] came out we shot i went
home never heard nothing about it again
you know i mean this is the [__]
problem
that people don't want to say [__] in
hollywood and then 20 years later
you want to be that girl and say josh
weldon had a toxic [__]
uh whatever like i said before
half of those [__] things are [__]
toxic i don't give a [__] what anybody
tells you
in one way or another even in the
simplest way because there's always
ego that's it when there's always an ego
you know i was watching miami vice
whatever the [__]
the other night and i was thinking about
a story i heard
the staff on miami vice would work all
day
would wait all day it would take them
five or six hours just to get the show
started
because who would come out of that
trailer first
is it going to be don johnson or the
black guy so don want the black guy to
come out
so he can make a bigger appearance
that's how my newt
of the [__] on the set happens that
people
like us really don't [__] have a clue
while we're watching the [__] show
my point of this whole [__] podcast
today is that listen man
i know you're angry i'm angry
i'm angry i lost 70 percent of my
friends
i lost 70 of my income
i i lost 50 of my friends 60 of my
friends
i don't know when my business is going
to come back my main business the thing
i live for all my life
i mean last week i was talking about
[__] retiring and not doing it
i couldn't imagine not doing comedy in
my life
but what's going on now if another
strain is coming
you know i don't know what's coming you
think i'm gonna be able to [__] not
do comedy for a year
and then get back on a [__] horse and
be the joey d as i was
i don't want to give you the joey dears
i want to give you the joey diaz
joey diaz treatment i want to go out
there and make you [__] puke
or say this is disgusting i got to go
home i want two reactions from you i
either want you
[__] laughing your ass off banging on
tables
i want you to say this is the most
disgusting stuff i've ever heard in my
life
i got to go home and put some holy water
in my [__] ears
that's the only thing i want to hear
from you that's
it that's how much i love and respect
you guys i don't want to go up there and
do a mediocre set
i got two shows fridays and saturdays
and uncle vinnie's
for my birthday you know i i don't know
what's gonna come out of my mouth i have
an idea
i've been doing a little bit of writing
at night but
wait till i get there wait till i put it
on stage
wait till i explode wait till i put my
energy into it
you know i got seven more shows to
decide what i want to do
i think the best thing about me with com
the thing i
the thing that i love the most that i
give joe cr
broken credit for is writing and putting
a bit together and putting it all
together
and how it all turns out at the end i
love that [__] i love
i love the first seven minutes i'm just
looking
for the first seven minutes you know i
don't know what's gonna happen
with the traveling or whatever but i
don't want to quit
stand up as a whole what i was saying is
that i'd rather do it more
as a hobby fall in love with it
and then re-attack it but the other
thing is
i don't want to go out on the road
while this country is in the state of
hate that we are right now
i love you guys i love having a great
time when i go on the road i love going
to your local restaurants
you know the last two years i got into
theaters
i would get to the theater you know i
don't want to sell no merchandise
the theater wants you i don't know if
you guys know that when you sell merch
or dinner they want 30
of your [__] merch so you know
and then i got to put glasses on and
look at the sizes
i don't i just want to go out there take
a picture with you and argue
the last [__] year the theaters
wouldn't let me do that they're like no
because we got a second [__] show
and you got to be out of here by a
certain time so if you go out there
you're going to disrupt everything
that kind of takes away from it even now
when i do the shows
uncle vinnie i can't have contact with
any of you guys
i made a promise i made a promise to
like three or four people
you know they asked me one guy is a
politician
and they said you got to do me a favor i
can't have you putting pictures up
anymore
with no mask i'd rather you not take
pictures and not [__] encourage that
you know the club owner has mentioned it
to me different club owners have
mentioned it to me that we're not
allowing
meet and greets you know yeah it's
coveted
and i get it but a meet and greet after
a comedy show
is the completion of a [__] circle of
our friendship
and that's how we move on to the next
one you know i want to thank my man bob
lalingus
for sending me some albums this week he
sent me sticky fingers
the original one with the [__] zipper
you could smell mick jagger's [__] when
you smell it
and he sent me another album but that's
going to be on the album of the week
out of order i usually on patreon i do
the album of the week
and the order was presented to me this
album is so cool
i'm doing it out of order now how did i
become friends with bob lolingis
and the people on the road it all
started with
a tweet a message i'm coming to your
show
we connect at the show we take a picture
and a headshot
he introduced me to his father and the
rest is history
and you guys know i got a thousand of
you guys all over the country
from jay bashero to my man in [__]
vegas
i got a thousand of you guys i down all
over the country now i wish i had ten
thousand of you [__]
i miss you more than ever now that we're
not doing [__] comedy
so please bear with me the other reason
why i don't want to go on the road is
we're not that's not that much love
i'm waiting every morning i wake up to
open up the computer
to hear about somebody got thrown with a
bottle at a comedy club
or something like that something bad
happened at a comedy club i don't want
to read that
and i don't want to read about one of my
friends we're not right normally how can
we be
we're living in a pandemic half of us
are inside half the time
half of us don't have money half of us
are not in contact with our people
half of our kids aren't in school you
can't fully be happy
me i've managed somewhere another to be
as happy as i can
despite losing money despite moving
i found a different happiness i found
the happiness within myself
if you see when i do these shows i don't
look like i did [__] 22 [__]
edibles the night before
i don't look like i'm half [__]
mummified i got brought back to life by
this [__] move you know
and i hurt i hurt just like you guys but
i'm not looking to hurt other people
right now i'm looking to lift people up
when i was a
16 year old [__] loser [__]
and i was hurt yes i was looking to hurt
other people and in any way i could
if i could step on an ant i would step
on an ant
just to make my day and that's what's
going on in today's world
and you have to lose that there's no
reason why you should be mad
anything that is not in within your
circle of life
you got to let it go because it's
affecting your life it's affecting your
relationship
it's affecting what you're doing at home
with your wife
you know let me tell you something every
day i pray
that we have not gone into it over this
pandemic me and my wife
not at all there have been a couple
disagreements but we've kept this house
in a really loving [__] way
i've had to work really hard on it we've
had our moments
before we left california my little
daughter was starting to break
i was starting to break i can't lie to
you my wife was starting to break
and what we would do every day is give
ourselves a group hug
and that would solve it you know we're a
family we're going to go through this
together
the same way we're going to go through
this together through this podcast
when i do this podcast i i i stop
smoking dope on this podcast i stop
doing a lot of things because
i want you to feel where i'm coming from
the old church was the church this is
the joint
this has something different i want you
to learn from a different perspective
and right now i want you to get over
whatever hurt you have
there's people that have lost 10 times
more than what you've lost they've lost
lifelong businesses they've lost mothers
they've lost fathers they had to say
goodbye
to their family on [__] face time so
much has happened since march
you know unless they [__] strike you
or attack you you know how many [__]
hear beatings
i've since i moved back to north bergen
i've lost three friends
like here or l.a friends
here north bergen friends
i've lost free north bergen friends just
because
that's just the way life is am i angry
about it am i upset
no god knows what's going on in their
head
when this all ends i make a circle back
but right now
it's not good do i hate them not at all
not at all not at all we go back to
[__] fall
we go back to when there was nothing how
can i [__] hate them
i love them even more i think about them
i call their friends that are mutual
friends of mine like check up on them on
the side
they just went off the reservation and
that's
accepted right now just listen if you
feel that
i'm not here pushing suicide hotline you
know me
i'm not here pushing a therapist here
i'm just here pushing friendship to you
i'm on a [__] computer i can help you
so much
if you send me an email you're feeling
bad i could say i can help you so much
you need human contact i don't care if
you got to join a gym for ten dollars
you know planet fitness
has a special for ten dollars if it
costs you ten dollars to go on there and
talk to two [__] little chubby chicks
and a [__] indian guy behind the
counter that gives you towels
so be it but nothing beats this
loneliness
nothing nothing this is horrible so i
know exactly where you're coming from
when you throw hate at me now you don't
see me [__]
lashing back at you because i could tell
you about things that happened a few
weeks ago
that would make you die that the cops
had to be called
the fbi got involved in it they know who
did it
now we're deciding what we're gonna do
with them and i'm saying no don't arrest
them
let them think that they got away with
it we got your address we know where you
live
it's just a matter of time you people
forget that we have church people all
over the [__] country
and they're all people that made
mistakes and they feel validated
because i do what i do because i tell
you the truth that just because you made
a mistake your life isn't over
and it's still not over right now people
are [__] walking around thinking
jesus christ look what happened to bruce
springsteen
jesus christ look what happened to gina
corrano jesus christ look what happened
this guy
for saying something for expressing
their [__] views
but gina carrano's fighting for herself
she don't give a [__]
and people are fighting for if you
believe in some and you said something
that you
fully have your heart behind it go for
it
but you know what man twitter facebook
all that stuff right now they're looking
to throw you off they're looking
to try i'm not mad at them i'm not mad
at them that there's got to be ton
tons of hate that goes through there
every [__] day
if it makes your life happy and get i
have a dear friend that got off facebook
couldn't take it anymore couldn't take
the hate on facebook it was affecting
him personally i know this guy 40
[__] years
get off but if you're in a state of hate
right now
the only advice i have for you is two
things
think about what you have think about
what you have accomplished
and think about what things you're gonna
accomplish once this pandemic is over
that's it don't focus on anything else
don't focus on the boss firing here he
gave my friend two more dollars because
of me
they have this and i don't have that you
know we'll get mad at people
got unemployment and then get mad at
people it's just too much anger and hate
going around
do not let it consume you find the
beauty in this pandemic
there's beauty i found it and i'm the
[__]
i'm the guy that looks for something bad
every [__] day
and i found the beauty of this [__]
pandemic i don't give a [__] what you
need to do
to find the beauty whether it's get i
eat a [__] tranny's [__] i don't
give a [__] what you need to do
so that's it and that's that
if you're angry or you feel like you're
being cheated
it's not just you man the world is doing
this to everybody
the world isn't [__] picking on you
life has peaks and valleys brother
and when i say peaks and valleys this is
when
you're making money when i say
valley doesn't mean that you're going
through a [__]
at gina carrano time i'm saying that you
you know we emotionally when i moved to
jersey
august 19th emotionally i was in a
[__] i was
deep in that [__] valley of debt i
could feel it
you know it doesn't mean that
everything's going against you
the world has nothing to do with it man
us ourselves we go up and down when you
look at baseball players
they go up and down brady went to ten
super bowls did he not
but he won seven we go up and down
there's peace and valleys the world
doesn't have any hate for you
god doesn't hate you it's just the state
of the world right now
that's it that's it and that's that so
it was valentine's day last night
if she didn't lick your balls the
chocolate syrup
today is your second chance [__]
thank you very much for watching uncle
joey's joint thank you for enjoying it
thank you for always sending me love
thank you for the patreon
i'll see you guys wednesday the 17th of
february
it's not going to be a good day for me
but i'm going to make it a good day for
you
i love you [__] and now for a
word from our sponsors
all right it's monday was a great little
time today on the joint but before we
leave
i gotta talk to you about something cbd
lion listen cbd is everywhere
everybody's talking about different cbds
i've been with these guys for two years
they sent me their products
i tried them and they were better than
anything else i had put on
the reason i like cbd line the most is
you go to their website and they break
it down for you
that is the most informative website on
cbd online
it tells you about the endocannable
system
how the cbd works with your body and
types of cannabinoids
what are terpenes ways to consume cbd
how to start using cbd that's what you
need to know
go to cbd line right now today pain
neck pain anxiety whatever you have
they can help you with the roll-on the
tincture
the kinesiology tape the gummy bears the
vapor pen
the kinesiology tape that's cut into
strips
i mean cbd lion has it all
dark chocolate milk chocolate however
you want to consume it however feels
best for you
cbd lion is there for you so do me a
favor go to cbdlion right now.com
read up on everything there is to read
before you make your decision
and i guarantee this is way better than
buying your cbd
at some liquor store on the corner from
some [__] guy that didn't even get
his ged
and there you are buying vodka oh i
should try cbd you [__] [__]
go to cbdlion.com right now press in
joey or church
and get 20 off delivered right to your
[__] crib that's how we're doing at
the cbd lion
the joint is also brought to you by lucy
nicotine gum let me tell you something
you know how it is to quit smoking it's
[__] hard when i did it
it was a nightmare i remember ralphie
may picking me up the next day
and smoking weed with me and [__] i
couldn't chase it with a cigarette
you know but i had to do what i had to
do i had to start with the patches with
gums and all that
and it was [__] a nightmare now it's
easy
you're down to one thing lucy nicotine
gun
when you're craving a smoke you just
need a little something to satisfy the
habit i mean the craving is like
60 to 90 seconds google it yourself
that's why i love lucy you step outside
you take a breath of fresh air
you pop this in your mouth and you're as
good as brand new tip
top [__] magoo it's 20 21 and
you're
still smoking outside with a bunch of
[__] moose freezing your ass off
it's over get lucy today so you're
prepared
when you get the itch to [__] smoke
keep it on you
so when your craving hits you're ready
to go and subscribe so you have it when
you need it
lucy gum actually tastes [__] good it
comes in three flavors the wintergreen
the cinnamon and the pomegranate if you
don't like the gum
they also got cherry ice flavored
lozenge that'll make your [__] wig
light itself on fire
my favorite flavor is the pomegranate
and the wintergreen
[__] tremendous so do me a favor
right now uncle joey listeners
the family go to lucy dot co ceo
lucy.co and use promo code joey
to get 20 off all products including
gum or lozenges that's lucy dot co
and use promo code joey at checkout also
i got to give you a little disclaimer
this is a warning you know the product
contains nicotine
derived from tobacco and nicotine is an
addictive chemical
go to lucy.com and be sure to use promo
code joey
and stop that [__] disgusting habit
all right
that's it and that's that thank you for
listening to the
joint on a monday morning the 15th of
february we're halfway there
it's my [__] birthday week and a lot
of other [__] bad memories
but we'll be back on wednesday morning
tip top magoo
ready to go i love you [__]
stay black
i need new candles